I see, I seem to have a stomach virus with cramping a diarrhea in oily stools,
silver, biotic, helped last week, but when I went off of it, the symptoms are back.
So a virus is how do you kill stomach virus, stomach bugs? Well, sometimes you've got to
kind of go through the course of it. We always remember that you have a knife machine at home,
so if it is a viral infection, running the viral programs are the way to go. If you feel like
you've got some sort of food poisoning, then there's other parasitic and bacterial infections
that you can run as well. So always go to for any type of bug that you might have at home,
whether it's strep or staff or anything like that should be your knife machine, and then
the other things that will help kill those things, hey, we talked about one called Burmary
today. That's great for your gut and got this biosis. Make sure you're taking a probiotic that
can help with balance your microbiota and try to get back on track.